So let's start again by looking at where ten and 16 fall in the distribution.
Ten is three points less than the mean, and 16 is three points greater than the
mean. So, if this is the mean, 13, this is ten, and here is 16. We're looking
for the area in between those two. How might we figure this out? Well, what
we'll do is, we'll find the area under 16, and then we'll subtract the area less
than ten. So what's the area less than 16? First, let's convert 16 to a z-score,
16 minus 13 divided by 4.8. So this is 0.625. Since ten is equidistant from 13
as 16 is, then the z-score for 10 is going to be negative 0.625. You can go
ahead and calculate that if you want. Sometimes that helps things make more
sense. So let's find the area less than a z-score of 0.625. We'll find 0.6 in
the vertical column and we'll have to round to the hundredths place, since
that's as detailed as the z-table gets. So we'll round to 0.63, so that's this
column and we should get 0.7357. And then, we'll subtract the area less than
ten, which has a z-score of negative 0.625. So here is negative 0.6 and here is
the column for 0.03, so the area less than negative 0.63 is 0.2643. Notice that
since these are the same values, just one is positive and one is negative, then
the area less than 0.625 plus the are less than 0.625 adds to one. So basically,
this area here, plus this area here equals one. That's because the area here is
equal to the area here. So, if you add 0.7357 and 0.2643, you should get one. So
that's just a property of the symmetry of the normal distribution. So if we
subtract them, we get 0.4714, and that's the area here in between 10 and 16.